[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and how you found this property okay
so is this the house here guys the
scripting screen is it yeah that's it
yeah okay
let's have a little look at it
so it looks like this might be going to
auction
okay there's an offer it's under offer
yeah it's going off for a 42. yeah
45 to 46. let's give it
there's an offer
okay
so it also looks like he needs quite a
lot of work
so matthew talk to me about how he
worked out the roi
how much did you budget for the refurb
so disclosure uh calendar
how do you realize that sometimes it's
very easy to underestimate a reefer
it's personal that's matthew a second
matthew what do you make of the fact
that it's a lot this whole they have
noticed there's but there's offers on
here i mean
sure yeah sure
how many of you think that like time
wise
you guys didn't have a lot of time
you know but
what's the lesson here
what's the what's the lesson
we
um this property itself
it looks like it needs a lot of work
it's got offers on it it might not be
quite as good as the door not to say i'm
not saying it's a terrible house but 35
percent of roi didn't factor in refurbs
didn't factor in the fact that it's
already enough for overdoses on the
table so what was the main lesson
throughout this exercise that you got
that being a terminal optimist might not
be enough yes how do you realize that
when you're doing deals
you've got to sometimes look at the
worst case scenario be conservative
listen guys
awesome so the first thing i'm saying i
actually think that this deal might be
decent even if you got it for 43 grand
and you spend five grand of
refurbishment it's still going to
probably give you a 20 roi still a good
deal so i think you smashed it
however i think you're a little bit
optimistic and rushed in time however
amazing job should we show these guys
some love where they tend to sit
down on the table already
oh these ladies are very excited
we made a couple of friends
we're saying
all right so so what pool road is again
[Music]
um
[Music]
the winner of this of this
gonna have the competition
to win a hundred pound prize for many
cash each right and he's saying well i
think my video maybe worth more than
that
i'm saying
i'm saying
[Applause]
apartments in bridge street i own number
16 and number 15 shoot a house bridge
straight so i know it well
oh wow
okay so this is this is this the one
is that the one yeah well it's 1075.
yeah so hold on
this went on auction for 45 grand and it
didn't sell at all is that correct
wow
that's very interesting i just sold
two properties
in that exact block
for sixty thousand pounds
last year
in that block number fifteen you can
check that you get the topics number
fifteen number 16 tudor house bridge
street i've sold them both for 60 rounds
they're on auction for 45 this one it
does this one just did a little bit of a
little bit of not even work it's more
just a messy town
so hit pitch it then jacob all right so
zombies oh it's on
45 000 uh the current tenant has been
there for a little while uh it's turned
out to be seven five but there is scope
for improvement my tenant was paying
four to five in that block yeah
so he didn't sell auction so how much
how much does that won um to be honest i
didn't ask that i should have asked uh
but i'm assuming that if you didn't
sound like this bro what do you think
now yes dude
all right let's find out
again
tomorrow
chambers it's one of the flights that
you've got 45 000.
is it an auction property or is it uh
okay
i will have to check with my colleagues
what was the procedure
so it's james watson
um
[Music]
okay oh fair enough fair enough
so
this property went on auction 45 grand
you spoke to the owner last week yes
and the owner said
so the person
but the agent said that it didn't sell
yes
okay so at the moment they'll probably
accept 45 cash for that property would
you agree guys
the probably said 45 cash it's probably
worth 16.
i don't know i know there's another
block i don't know why it didn't sell as
interesting it might need a few hundred
pounds rent 400
the roi and that's going to be very high
there is because it's a lease on
property there is a small ground rent
service charge every year
from memory i think it's about 600
pounds i like that apartment
all right anyone thinking guys
you were a team
you were a team
now
that awesome flat is a good opportunity
went to auction didn't sell however
it's a good opportunity it's not a deal
okay you're right jacob you can sell
deals for three to four grand but a deal
is when you've got an firm's
wrapped up
sale price
you haven't got that jacob you've just
got an opportunity is that fair
however it's a hot leader's lead i like
and it's on my turf it's in warsaw
so here's what i'm going to say
you've got two options
option number one is you can try and
turn together you can work together on
this you guys are a crew
you can try and work together
on that lead and speak to the agent wait
from school you back and try and secure
it and try and sell it yourself and
either you can keep it jacob do you
think or the three of you can team up
whatever you want that's option number
one or option number two
is as you worked as a team and you were
together i am prepared to give you
100 pounds
cash
each
for your team efforts
and finding the lead and then
and then hold on if you take the money
though it's going to happen
then i will take over
this little conversation with the agent
it becomes my lead
okay
hold up guys hold on guys now
we've been being a little bit messy a
little bit a little bit complicated
because there's three of them
jacob found the deal they kind of work
together
do they sell it do they keep it or do
they take the money would it be fair
to give them an opportunity to have a
team meeting yes or no yeah so i'm going
to give you guys an opportunity to have
team members just what you want to do so
i'm going to give you a total to decide
and if you go because after the team
meeting by the way if you're actually
but still undecided guess what
guess what i'm going to keep the money
and i'll keep the deal
how many reasons about how many words
you need to make quick decisions in
business yes or no
is that fair guys
so you team me and i'm going to give you
a total of 15 uh 15 seconds
have a drum roll
and after the drum roll they're going to
announce what they're going to do i'm
going to take a banana
please
[Music]
[Applause]
fair enough so in that case one two
three four five there's a hundred pounds
that's you jacob congratulations also as
well
oh you dropped 20 i'll keep that bit
there you go we also got
one two three four five another hundred
pounds there you go kirsten welcome
kirsten
and then finally the last 100 pounds
jacob
okay so my name is jacob watson
i came back to the crash course after
not being here i haven't been here for
two and a half years
um just uh to be honest i come today
just to find some clients you know
network see if i can build up my network
myself
and they had a deal sourcing challenge
and i luckily um i used to have some new
leads do prove something released so
deal sourcing and james armstrong shout
out james armstrong um geosourcing is uh
my bread and butter so in this deal
sourcing challenge stuck it on us to
find the deal so it was an auction
property that's just coming back on the
market because it's denzel at auction so
it's motivated seller it's proper winner
for it for anybody involved i know some
of you leads came and said okay so would
you like 300 pounds for the deal right
now or would you like to go away take it
away um so stack it and package it um i
said i'll take the money right now uh
that's for one reason i already saw
stacking package deals and i've got a
bunch of deals check out rental property
uh we've got a number of deals come here
with a number of deals so i thought you
know what the one thing i can do is
maybe show it's a good deal anyway
samuel took the deal off us
um you know he essentially you know said
oh this is a good deal this is what this
is what i'm interested in and named
after things fact that is uh you know
motivated sellers auction property i
didn't go to auction you know he in fact
said it's a block of flats or within a
block that he owns all the properties
and it was listed at less than the
properties that he owned so already it's
bottle market value um and yeah so i
thought it'd be a good opportunity to
kind of
piggyback on the you know the energy
that sammy release brings and hopefully
find some new clients so if yourself are
looking for properties in and around the
west midlands wolverhampton dudley
warsaw birmingham's medic anywhere like
that check out
rentonproperty.co.uk and uh
give me a call on a serious note like
since my first question because i came
to the first crush course
when i first came to the crash course it
was a weird one so i actually had a
heart problem and i
just dropped out university so i was
gonna give a weird place and i ended up
working
for some of your leads and i just i
ended up saying to alistair actually
that's interesting kind of work for you
guys for a while i'm a smart enough guy
i work hard this is all like you know i
kind of try to you know the elevator
pitch you're trying to name all the
stuff that you could i'll do this i'll
do this i'll do this and then boom boom
boom fast forward all these years later
and you know what aside from money the
biggest thing that i'm grateful about is
like and this is like serious stuff is
the mindset change because i had
like
no my circles weren't i'm just people it
was pretty great my circles went you
know you know what i mean and um
coming here it opens your eyes man it
opens your eyes because in a weird way
like you know for me i was raised to
believe that it's either you know you go
university or you just don't exist in
the world basically my parents are like
you go university go just go there so
when i left it was a big old kind of
like meant to buy it to get over and
come to samuel leaves
and you know it's weird because i'm anti
i'm anti the sales part honestly bro i
don't like it i don't like doing all the
big big up things but like now i came
here and um people here elliot spencer
amazing guy james armstrong alistair all
of those guys they just made such a good
environment to be in that was infectious
and i guess it infected the rest of my
life
you